投資朋友歡迎收聽早晨財經速解讀,
現在是臺北時間2026年10月7號禮拜三,
早上8點31分,
大家早安,
我是學廷浩。
每天早上開盤前半小時,我們在這邊陪伴著各位一起解讀國際財經新聞時事變化。
那這次美國股市週二是全面收高,
原油價格趨穩的情況底下,
公債殖利率也開始回落,
讓美國股市標普白指數突破了7800點。
如果我們細看
這一輪已經是今年標普500指數
第28次創下歷史新高了
其實美國股市從過去08年以後
長期就保持在高強度牛市
28次在今年的創下歷史新高
也不是說特別多次了
去年就已經39次了
前年是57次
2022年當時受到烏二戰事的影響
也有一次創下新高
21年70次
20年33次
所以美國股市的三代牛
格局從1929年到現在
的確常常在一輪的股災之後
它可能要花三到四年
甚至五到六年來收復師徒
但是當它收復師徒以後
連續多年的創高
就變成了美國股市的三代牛
那現在細節來做觀察
如同我們過去所提到的
標普白指數的確是創下歷史新高了
不過真正上漲的股票
其實並沒有想象中還要來得多
如同我們看到內部的分化
從9月中旬低點以來
像是超維或者我們看到美超維
intel上漲幅度都來到20%以上
可是呢在部分中小型個股層面
其實賣壓還是相對來的比較沉重一點
舉幾個指數來做觀察
一個是昨天我們提到的標普等權指數
現在距離歷史高點還是低了接近5%
在500家公司當中
成分股大概只有三分之一
的確從9月中旬以來是上漲的
有三分之二從9月中旬以來
就過去半個月反而是下跌的
8月份我們看公用事業類股
跌幅是有接近10%
到現在非必需類品
現在也跌了大概有5%
所以這就是現在市場上最大的矛盾
從5月底以來
標普白指數本身只上漲幾個百分點
但是企業獲利卻被上修了21%
所以高值利率沒有把大型科技股
擊垮的真正原因是什麼呢
就是利率繼續向上
但是財務體值比較高
負債比較高的公司
整體來說在小型股層面
或者說非大型科技股層面
它先撐不住了
可是它不影響到指數的重大傷害
那大型科技股呢
現在反而是獲利持續的做拉伸
所以反而讓整體估值變得越來越便宜
你也沒什麼理由繼續去賣它了
所以如果從高利率來看
不能說是沒有壓力
這是沒有反應在大型科技股當中
現在從高點來做計算
在美股還沒有獲利的科技股
大概是回撤平均是19%
房地產和公用事業類股
平均下跌15%
REITs下跌10%
小型股跌9%
生技股大概跌8%
好那相對於
我們看到大型科技股
目前正在創新高
所以高利率不是說沒有傷害
但是就沒有傷到最大的那幾只
所以一樣是大則橫大
我們舉幾檔來說
像是超微的部分
在昨天股價是上漲2.8%
放下列舉新高價
這一次蘇之鋒禮拜二也是拜會了臺灣
像是臺積電的代工的大廠
也表示會宣佈在臺灣擴大投資
再投資100億美元的供應鏈
這AMD要變成TMD了
那這一次主要是來自於AI
以及CPU需求的持續增長
他預估明年可能成長速度會來得更快
所以必須要跟臺積電和臺灣的封裝
測試 載板等供應鏈
來準備要進行擴散的合作
預估在27年會大幅增加CPU GPU和AI產品的供應
蘇之鋒自己也承認
AMD目前的規劃產能時間尺度已經完全改變了
以前大概就談一到兩年
而且很常那種談半年突然抽單
不好意思景氣好像沒有如想象中來得好
現在蘇之鋒承認已經拉長到三到五年
希望能夠提前去鎖定晶圓封裝和其他關鍵的產能
雖然他也強調說
我們也是希望把供應鏈
往不同國家來分散
可是很抱歉
現在最終還是要從臺灣來出貨
所以不如跟臺灣的幾隻供應鏈大佬
陸續來做拜會
包括鴻海的劉文偉董事長
還有臺積電等相關的合作伙伴
都是如此
那另外他的重要的競爭對手
輝達這一次股價
一樣創下歷史性高價了
市值大概在5.8兆美元左右
那他應該是全球即將第一家
突破到6兆美元企業的市值
這很難想象
前幾年它也不過幾千億美元的市值
然後突破1兆
然後突破2兆
突破3兆
今年股價上漲30%
所以今年又增加了1.3兆
現在5.8兆
也是標普白指數上漲14%
今年以來最大的貢獻者
你要知道今年3月份的時候
輝達是一度下跌11%
結果現在漲回來了
市場當時也很擔心說
AI基礎建設
到底數千億美元能否產生足夠的回報
現在到底有沒有回報不知道了
但是輝達的回報肯定是來了
輝達預估在整個27年的財年營收會大幅增長90%
淨利會接近翻倍
那公司甚至預估在2028年財年的營收
也可以持續增長70%
這真的很難想象
因為5.8兆
你要知道把它拿來跟幾個國家來做對比
現在大概就僅次於日本股市的6.2兆
它已經揮達一家公司的市值
已經比英國股市市值來得高
3.48兆
臺灣是3.44兆
加拿大是3.43兆
中國是3.03兆
我們看應該看港股的部分
所以我們看不同市場
拿來做不同層面的進行比較
你會發現投資人現在買賣的
已經不只是單純一家晶片公司
而是一家市值足以超越
中國應該不是了
中國的數據應該有
它主要應該反映的是單一指數的變化
可是不管怎麼說了
我們講的是單一公司的估值膨脹到國家級的級別
它可能對於全球ETF和資金的影響
略如想象中還要來得大
其實如果我們從今年標普白指數第三季的獲利成長幅度
前十名的貢獻大概已經包辦68%的獲利成長了
美光大概佔了19%
輝達大概佔了15%
兩家公司加起來就34%了
Meta加阿帕貝和博通
再貢獻7% 6%
還有5%
所以從這幾隻公司來看
光是半導體
大概就把全球能夠賺到的錢
都已經全部給賺走了
好 重點就來自於
可是揮達的估值本益比
真的如同想象中來的高嗎
我們如果是從當前本益比來看
就先不看前瞻
其實我們前瞻
你未來幾個季度揮達賺多少錢
我們大概也知道了
但重點是我們先不用前瞻
就用當前本益比
當時在2023年的時候
整體本益比大概是150倍
然後到2024年大概是95倍
2024年底67倍
2025年55倍
到現在38倍
可是如果我們以今年年底
到明年年初的前瞻本益比來做估算
現在本益比更低了
大概是多少呢
17.2倍
這個本益比的倍數
它就遠遠低於
第一是今年每一戰事的低點
還要來得更低
第二比去年關稅戰還來得更低
第三比23年24年來得更低
第四比烏俄戰事開打時
當時整個2022年的低點都還來得低
差不多甚至比2020年的新冠疫情
都還來得低
這個就是我們看到的
輝達的本益比概況
怎麼會市值都要挑戰5.8兆
都要挑戰6兆了
結果輝達的本益比
居然低到10年的最低
當然不是因為股價便宜
是因為市場已經上修的
它的獲利速度
比股價上漲速度實在快太多了
你要知道今年其實輝達
還算是跑輸整個非半指數
非半今年漲幅大概是87%左右
美光 Marvell Intel上漲都超過200%
所以輝達已經是全球市值最大的公司
它現在有90%的營收成長
但是預估本益比還不到18倍
這個就很有趣的局面了
所以全世界最大的公司
它的本益比
不像是以前的蘋果這麼高
反而越來越低
就是由於它的獲利增長
實在太快了
好那問題就來了
你到底是在買它的股價
還是在買它的機器
其實在今年FANG的表現
揮達如果在裡頭的話
表現已經算差勁的
最大贏家當然是美光了
年初到現在是上漲273%
揮達的部分是29%
蘋果上漲22% Meta是12%
Alphabet Amazon分別上漲11% 10%
微軟大概是10%左右
博通9.4%
Parenteer 8.3%
最弱的就是Netflix
今年反而大跌了2成7
所以其實輝達他頂多就是作為一個穩盤的角色
有很多其他的廢辦的成分股都在向前帶動衝
AI現在大家泡沫最大的矛盾是什麼
其實就陸續出來了
就是所有人都知道風險
但是企業獲利看起來還追得上股價
我們當然知道現在市場上最大的風險
就是史上最大規模的資本支出
投資金額快速膨脹
產業也正在快速的重壓這些巨頭
企業之間彼此的投資和採購
管理層也沒有那種認為投資過度的擔憂
都認為投資太少比投資太多
更危險的這樣的一個相關擔憂
所以這個時候我們就要來做一些比較
從宏觀數據來做一些追蹤
到底有沒有可能資本支出還沒有停止
股價我們就先提前見到頂點了
如果從數據來看
企業資本支出其實反而是落後指標
股價它為優先權反映未來
我們以2000年來看
2000年3月份納斯達克見頂的時候
美國的IT資本支出年增幅還是高達15%
企業還在投資
大概是13個月之後
IT的支出增長率大概才跌破0
所以換句話說
說當年的企業當年股市也不是等到
企業停止花錢才崩
其實CAPEX就是股價不漲了
它都還在衝
現在也有類似警惕的地方
就是今年大概第二季
美國IT的資本支出年增幅是19%
比網絡泡沫還要更快
納斯達克現在也處於高檔
所以我們要提醒的就是
不能說AI泡沫一定要破
是我們不能說
因為科技巨頭還在瘋狂投資AI
所以股市未來就不會見頂了
我們要看的是一個市場衡量的關係
股價能不能更進一步的反應
一方面極其的下滑
另外一方面
我們預估資本支出
不會說明年就停下來
這是第一層角度
就本來就會有時間線的關係
第二層角度是通常
資本支出什麼時候掉下來呢
通常是股價見頂之後
等個半年到兩年才跟著下完
從幾次的經驗
你像1929年
美國的公用失業泡沫
大概落後一年
89年的日本泡沫大概落後是8個月
2000年是7個月
14年美國頁岩油熱潮大概落後5個月
所以其實不管怎麼說
都是股價先優先在前面
你也不能夠等到資本支出
真的已經完全遞還了
你才認為本輪行情已經結束
到時候股票市場搞不好就已經先跌了
所以資本支出本來就是一個落後指標
我們重點還是觀察股市的情緒
而股市我認為現在最安全的地方
就是剛才提到的
它本益比就這麼低
低到這麼離譜的地步
你也很難去賣它
而這就是我認為
最根本對於這些科技巨頭
你覺得好像有風險
但是你又覺得
好像不該賣它的主要原因
另外一個值得警惕的地方
當然是市場集中度
因為美國現在對大型企業
佔整體股市的比重
已經來到40多年來
極端高的位階
標普500前十大的企業
好像整體而言
如果我們細看總體權重
大概已經佔了
整個指數40%左右
這個就比2000年網絡泡沫27%的高點來得高了
這好事也壞事
好事就是你知道
其實握有AI技術的企業
不過就是這幾家
他不是人人說自己是AI
市場就給你高估值
現在往往是市值最大的
體量最大的
估值稍微也給你比較高一點
因為你擁有AI的權利
跟那種網絡泡沫時代
人人皆稱自己是網絡公司
其實有比較大的區別
尤其前十大企業佔標普500
未來12個月的獲利
預估大概有37%
也是創下利率新高
所以它不只是大
它是真的很會賺
所以從這樣的一個角度來做觀察
那就是典型泡沫
一個最大的不同
一般泡沫後期都是股價上漲速度
會超過獲利速度
現在我們看到的效果是什麼
獲利速度比股價上漲速度還要來得快
最後你以前都只能
未來會更好來合理化
越來越誇張的估值
現在估值就沒貴
變貴
揮打股價創高的時候
獲利比股價創高速度來得快
所以才會導致
怎麼本益比居然創下10年新低
這就是最離譜的
股價都已經要挑戰6兆美元了
然後你告訴我
本益比是10年來的新低
所以這個就是多空雙方
非常強而有力的證據
空頭可以說
現在幾兆美元的科技巨頭
綁在一塊
投入到這些基礎建設
不斷的創紀錄
然後又集中在少數的AI公司
這就是歷史泡沫
多頭就可以反問
如果它真的是典型的泡沫
為什麼最核心
市值最大的輝達
它的獲利成長速度
居然比股價還來得快
本益比降到這10年來的低點
我們的態度一直以來都是後者
這是給投資評論處的一些觀察和思考
當然我們常常不是不知道答案
我們才常發生的是搞錯了問題
就是你看輝達市值
現在突破即將挑戰6兆
你第一個直覺都覺得
六兆就很貴了
但這個問題有時候
可能一開始就問錯了
公司市值很大
也不代表股票貴
一家市值100億美元
卻完全不賺錢的公司
也有可能比一家市值
只有一兆美元
每年賺幾百億美元的公司
來得更貴
真正我們要觀察的效果是
估值從來都不是市值的絕對數字
你要看的是這家公司
是不是大家相信
能夠創造更多的獲利和現金流
所以這個是給大家做的一些請示
我們常常不是不知道答案
我們是搞錯了問題
現在小學課有健康課
之前看了兒子回家
問了爸爸一個問題
爸爸食道跟陰道有什麼區別
爸爸面對這個突如其來的問題
有點難為情
不過這也是一個性教育的好機會
就接近所能
解釋清楚
食道跟陰道都是人體的管道
它們屬於不同的系統
食道是消化系統
連接嘴巴和胃
吃飯喝水
會進入到胃
陰道是女性的生殖系統
連接身體外部和子宮
月經流出身體的通道
也是自然生產時
寶寶會出生
會經過的一些地方
講完滿頭大汗
小朋友很驚恐
怎麼這樣
老師說
今天上課陰道22人
10到18人
我們常常不是不知道答案
我們是搞錯了問題
你不要問6兆美元
是不是太大
你要看的是
揮達的獲利
能不能嚐到足以支撐6兆7兆
甚至更高的市值
這就是最有趣的地方
輝達市值已經比大多數國家的
整體股市市值還要來得高
但它的本益比
未來12個月從原本的100倍
80倍70倍60倍
到現在不到18倍
創下10年低點
你回過頭看就會發現
市場上修獲利的速度
是遠遠比股價上漲的速度
還要來得更快
當然
它其實也帶動了整個標普白指數
某種程度而言
整體估值也不算貴
不只是回答不貴
其實整個標普
就是由這幾隻大型科技股所組成
整體來看大家就不貴了
從整個26年第三季標普500
因為很快財報季就要開始
預估年增幅大概是27%
如果我們從中位數來看
你發現好像就不高了
剩下9%
所以第一件事情
其實有非常高強度
集中在少數個股
來支撐指數的味道
如果你是投資單一個股
績效跑速大盤
我必須承認
今年都很正常
前幾年都也很正常
因為前幾年就漲大型科技股
就算是今年
它可能也是漲少數費辦晶片股
所以導致你的績效
會有比較大的一個落差
我們假設
你就算是投資費辦裡頭的成分股
你今年平均報酬
也要漲幅來到80%以上
才算是跑贏費辦
所以這就是投資指數
跟投資個股當中
比較大的一個挑戰
尤其有個股在資金分配的一個問題
所以一個是中位數
一個是平均數
平均數是27%
中位數只有9%
所以其實獲利是高強度
集中在少數個股當中
指數很強
但多數股票並沒有想象中來的大
從整體獲利的貢獻值
我們剛才提到
整體獲利增量最大的
基本上就美光
美光大概是佔了19%
前十大企業
輝達是15%
然後Meta是7%
阿發貝是6%
所以就靠這幾次了
那如果我們把產業差距來看
那就更離譜了
能源業的美股盈餘是今年
由於受惠於美伊戰士
來到109%是局管
資訊科技是64%
通訊服務和原物料是3x8和3x6
相對之下
你看臺灣跟美國金融業是兩種極端
臺灣金融業今年創高了
結果美國金融業今年只成長1%
最慘的是什麼
是美國的非必須消費
是零
民生必須消費
甚至為福衰退
所以從這樣的一個角度來看
你就可以稍微理解
為什麼道瓊最近好像有點弱了
在美國的實業
美國的實體經濟概況
的確比想象中還要來的差一點
所以高值利率有沒有影響
有
第一個對於揮打的影響是低本一筆
但不代表低股價
第二
高值利率的影響反映在哪裡
其實還是看中小型股
或者美國的實業股
現在就看
利率如果維持在這個區間
小型股能不能穩住
就你不要再升高
也許對我來講就是一個利多了
羅素2000的部分
這幾天其實嘗試的在陸續站穩
近期大概已經重新站上了200日均線
我們把它當年線了
至少已經嘗試的突破
8月中旬以來的下降趨勢
而且最近幾個交易日
很明顯反彈幅度也很快
開始跑贏標普派指數了
現在值得注意的事情就是
羅素2000
因為它是一個比較明顯的下行通道
尤其槓桿基金對於小型股的空單
現在又來到歷史高點
所以小型股現在不一定需要
連準會大幅降息才能夠反彈
你只要稍微不小心急彈
你就有可能引發大量的空頭回補
也許本場的高值利率
高利率衝擊
也許就能夠稍微緩解了
不過利率到底預期能夠有多好
這也很難說了
因為原油價格雖然最近回跌
布蘭特原油最近跌3.3%
每桶大概回到98塊左右
吸的都跌到87塊
可是它也不代表能源危機解除
還是很貴
尤其現在又有一點外溢的效果
舉例來說
你像在今年
大宗商品的最為強勢資產
開始變成了白糖
白糖在9月底的現貨價格
已經漲幅超過22%
明顯超越標普白指數12%的漲幅
背後是什麼原因
就來自於全球供給的快速收緊
歐盟是受到高溫的影響
預估糖產量會大幅下滑19%
巴西中南部的產量
大概也下滑了接近10%左右
有一部分是來自於聲音現象
巴西印度和泰國
大概就佔了全球糖出口的70%左右
那也沒關係
大家少吃糖
這不是重點
重點是原物料價格
仍然有顯著的外溢效果
我們從過去單軸來看
漲最多的是糖
可是從今年以來
全球原物料價格
有很大一部分
還是圍繞著農糧價格
漲最多的還是能源了
像樂蘭油漲了107%
汽油今年漲了86%
布蘭特原油漲了61%
西德州52%
糖價今年已經漲了三成八了
另外我們往下來做延伸
像是銅價黃豆棉花橡膠
其實雖然從大宗資產來看
是一半上漲一半下跌了
可是上漲的幅度
相對於下跌幅度
那是兩種極端
這說明今年其實還是有比較明顯的通膨外溢效果
能不能讓利率預期能夠有效的回落
其實有點難度
說明雖然羅素2000最近開始反彈
但是我們看起來更多是反映持穩的態勢
而並不是現在預估很有可能
接下來利率預期就能夠全面的消失
這個是值得大家觀察重點
這也說明著
其實本輪我們看到估值不高的原因
其實就來自於高利率
那高利率的不高
所以導致本益比無法往上做推升
其實對於美國股市也是一件好事
它就是永遠告訴你說
你們不要毫無止境的借錢玩下去
你可以藉由各種方式
對於你而言
找到更好的方式來借錢
那應該產生的效果是
排擠其他企業的借錢效果
如果是AI也在借錢
非AI也在借錢
那麼就有可能資金不夠
或者流動性問題
或者它就有泡沫的問題
可是AI一直借錢
而且還把非AI的錢都給借走了
把房貸也給借走了
實業股的錢也給借走了
那我勉強還可以把它
當成一種存量上的轉移
那這場遊戲還玩得下去
所以你說現在是全面性的繁榮嗎
至少從非AI族群來看
也並不是如此
我們舉例來說
像SpaceX在昨天正式宣佈
準備再度籌措400億美元
直接來購買輝達的AI晶片
其中100億美元會來自銀行貸款
300億美元會透過投資等級債的債券來做籌資
由阿波羅來做主導
交易預估會在27年左右才會完成
那輝達其實過去我們也看到了
馬斯克早就已經表態說
SpaceX的AI運算幾乎是全面壓住輝達
尤其看好新一代的VRubin架構
更值得注意的事情是
SpaceX6月份才完成公開募股860億
不到兩週又發行250億
現在又告訴你
我又要發400億
所以他也是瘋狂的搶錢
SpaceX雖然現在是Triple B
也算是投資等級債
可是到2056年的到期債券
目前價格只剩下面額的85%
殖利率比美國公債高了2.27%
所以等同於他發行的債券
大概都是7%到8%的殖利率左右
那信用利差
其實差不多要接近垃圾債水準
他為了搶到這筆錢
都給你非常高的回報
所以其實我們看到這裡
我們也不用太糾結
自己到底有沒有壓對AI
因為世界就很小
你以為別人的問題
最後大家都要捅一掌往裡頭
你覺得AI估值太高
所以你就不買科技股
你跑去買債券避險
現在科技巨頭為了要蓋資料中心
也是為了買GPU大量發債
你買的企業債
你可能就是在替AI融資
你把錢交給退休基金
保險公司
你以為做最保守的資產配置
這些機構大概又是去承接科技公司的債券
所以到最後你以為自己離AI很遠
其實你只是從AI股東換了一個位置
可能變成了AI債權人之類的
最後你發現AI公司的資本支出
輝達的營收
銀行的貸款
基金的部位
你幾乎就全部連在一起了
世界就是這麼小
原來我的錢永遠都已經對賭AI了
所以這些問題它是一個大問題
那對於圍觀而言,它就不是問題了嘛
之前講兩個男的一起打高爾夫嘛
那打到一半,其中一個突然想起
外套放在,忘在上一棟
那走回去拿,那走到一半,突然停下來
然後轉身走回到朋友旁邊
那朋友問怎麼了嗎,那男的很尷尬
前面那兩個女人,一個是我老婆,一個是我情婦
好像走過去有點麻煩
那朋友笑了,那這有什麼,那我幫你拿嘛
那朋友往前走,結果走到一半他也回來了
那男的問這又怎麼了
那朋友沉默了一下
這世界真小
所以大家本來都以為自己只是站在旁邊
看AI的熱潮
有些人選擇不參與
但你雖然選擇不參與
你大概也參與了
因為世界這麼小
原本你的錢可能也參與其中
不是郭董
甚至你說我連債都不要
我就去買最傳統最防禦性的公司
問題是今天從銀行到工業到電力
你覺得你買的電力公司跟AI沒有相關
你買的工業公司跟電力沒有相關
你買的零售跟AI沒有相關
大家都在談AI轉型
都在蓋資料中心
增加電力投資
導入AI代理人
更不用講標普白指數
前十大公司已經佔了指數的40%
全部都做AI
你根本就無法逃離AI
最後你只是換了一條路
重新鬧回AI
所以這個年代最有趣的地方就是
我們表面上一直在想說
要不要參與本場可能充滿泡沫的AI行情
答案就是
不管你願不願意
只要你還在股市債券退休基金
在這個金融體系裡頭
你多少都已經在這張網裡頭了
你發現這個世界就這麼小
OK所以這給投資朋友注意思考
好我們看美歐股市四大指數表現
道瓊指數上漲253.0.49%
是在51521點
嘗試的站回半年線
標普上漲44.0.58%
是在7818點
創下歷史新高價
納斯達克指數上漲122.0.45%
算27,599點歷史新高
費辦上漲45.0.34%
算13,217點
其實從目前美國股市估值來看
標普和納指的創高
其實已經意味著整個大盤算是屈穩了
現在就看費辦能不能順勢追漲
道瓊反而偏弱一點是可以接受的
因為這是屬於成分股的性質不同所造成的
當然現在市場上就是
又怕AI估值可能會很高
我們剛剛已經講了
而本益比其實沒這麼高
你又害怕錯過行情
有些人的做法可能是以科技核心持股
加現機選擇權的方式來做進行
就假設這樣子
你本來想要100%all in大盤
可是你又遇到了一個問題
就如果真的遇到AI泡沫破滅
大盤又跌了三成
已經沒錢加碼了
你其實可以換另外一種思維
就股票不一定是要買整體SPY買大盤
你可以更為集中到可能臺股
可能QQQ
可能SOXX
這類科技或者半導體型的ETF
因為如果未來美股繼續創高
那AI和科技股有很高的幾率
還是會重要的推升力量
那這個時候你就可以有保留現金了
以前會害怕保留現金
那就要落後給大盤績效了
現在就是那你買科技指數
那你就可以保留10%到20%的現金
波動幅度稍微加大
但是AI股本來就是如此
雖然你沒有100%滿倉
但是你有更高的科技曝顯
去維持上漲的參與度
這裡有一點類似
現金選擇權
就是你由於大量集中在這些科技股
讓你沒有完全錯過行情
但如果AI真的充滿了
比較大的一個估值回調
跌了三成跌了四成
你手上的現金
這個時候就值錢了
因為別人只滿倉
你只能看著它跌
你有低檔加碼的權利
而且你的最後總體績效
還是有機會能夠超越整個大盤
因為如果股市創高
很高的幾率還是靠AI
所以現金的價值不能只用今年少賺多少來做衡量
有時候他買的是未來市場出現極端價格的時候
你還有出手的能力
這給投資朋友做的一些參考
有些人就想參與想all in
但是又不敢all in
那不敢all in又怕自己跑出給大盤
那你就進攻一點的資產
搭配的適度的現金保留
我認為也是一種方式
我最近在慕尼黑
本來網友都跟我開玩笑
說德鐵真的很常誤點
我後來發現真的很常誤點
而且是有一點離譜的
都是晚到30到
可能一個小時左右
只要是到郊區的
後來有一個網友就跟我分享
一個很有趣的做法
叫做德鐵的暗黑兵法
它就是你故意去訂
每週五最晚最便宜
然後最容易誤點的ICE
這邊就解釋德鐵的票制
德鐵有一種便宜的
特別的票叫SPAPI
就是你可以把它理解成
找鳥票
價格很便宜
它代價都是可能它會有綁定列車
你買的是哪一班的ICE
你原則上就必須要搭那一班
你不能看到前面有一班車
你就提前那我先上去
不能這樣子
那有趣的地方就在這邊
如果你原本預估抵達目的地
可能會延遲20分鐘以上
那在符合得鐵的規則情況底下
這個綁定列車的限制就會解除
就你不用再死守原本那班車了
所以你可能只花了15歐元
你買了一張限制很多的SPA品
然後就找鳥票
結果碰到大霧點
你就取得了未來更多的改大的彈性空間
你就可以選擇其他符合規定的列車
來前往目的地
那整套策略最好笑的地方是什麼
就是你最大的風險就是怕它準點
那好在就是它很少準點過
而且通常一霧點都是30分鐘
50分鐘
一兩個小時起跳
所以正常人買得鐵就最怕霧點
那這群人就反過來
他怕得鐵準時這樣子
那這其實就選擇權交易
就15歐元的SparP
就早鳥票
有點像是你付出的權利金Premium
就是預估延遲超過20分鐘
那一旦條件觸發以後
原本被綁死的低價票
你就等同於算是解鎖了更大的彈性空間
當然你不能說15歐元車票
最後就變100歐元
然後你現賺85
因為你不能把這張票拿去市場上賣掉
但你買的是什麼
你買的是增加的權利
所以我們要回過頭來說
這件事情套回到投資
有趣的不是選擇權
這三個字
是你能不能把自己的位置設計成
原本大家害怕的事情發生時
你反而得到更多選擇
好
現在我們在做投資的過程當中
就很多人就是害怕
可是都沒有跌
從7月份以來
我怕我現在又all in
那股市更集中
到時候沒有現金加碼
那你就買科技型的ETF
進攻一點點
那你保留10%到20%的現金
這樣的一個報酬結構
你未來就有更多的選擇權了
反而到時候真的跌了三成跌四成
你就觸發手上的現金價值
別人已經滿倉
我只能承受下跌
但我卻突然取得了低價加碼的權利
這就一種做法
所以其實對於現在的當前行情
有不同的做法來做參與
差別的在於
那你最終看不看好AI
你認不認為現在估值到極端離譜的貴呢
那我個人的看法是
其實撇開一切
它就是沒這麼貴
這是我的看法
好 臺股小跌35點
所在49780熱點
我們今天主要是跟投資朋友
稍微分享一下高爾夫球跟得體
不是分享一下
第一是高折利的影響
其實陸續在呈現
不過我們從輝達的創高
從超維的創高
它的背後
其實反映的是估值又創低了
那要如何理解這樣的跡象
其實就是
把它拿來跟2000年對照
目前獲利上升的速度
是遠遠大於
目前股價上升速度的
這個跡象出現的時候
其實在牛市出現也不常見的
牛市通常都要提前反應
但是你卻發現
既然股價創高了
估值變低了
那我覺得仍然是機會
那當然在操作的過程當中
會受到不同層面的高支利率
融資循環
估值回調
川普政策的影響
可能股價始終會有回調
所以在操作策略上
也許你還是可以達到心中
比較符合自己心中一塊的那種做法
也許也不是說一股腦子
就完全相信AN要all in
他有不同的做法
來參與本輪的AI行情
讓你擁有更多的選擇權
謝謝投資朋友
多謝參考
就是林志鵬
如果喜歡我們節目
記得幫我們訂閱按贊加分享
我們就要明天早上半半
找成財經速解讀
再相見
祝各位投資朋友
看完順利
操盤愉快